[Applaudissements]
je vous dis j'ai une surprise de fou
pour l'un d'entre vous et gilles reste
avec nous bien sûr parce que ce soir
c'est aussi votre soirée pour le moment
on a une vidéo et un garçon qui
s'appelle david regarde on va bas déjà
je suis fan de toi je suis autant fan de
toi que ma femme mes fans dames hier
donc voilà on se marie bientôt et si tu
veux lui faire un cadeau franchement je
t'en serai éternellement reconnaissant
ça sera un truc de ouf je t'embrasse
baba et surtout reste toi même qu'on
bisous
sauna est david alors valide ma femme
parce que 20 ans et la femme elle est
fan d'avenir et il y en a une qui a
voulu te faire une très très grosse
surprise
regardez ça valérie bénaïm elle s'invite
dans tous les mariages actrice
regardez c'est la grande régala de baba
lantin ça c'est très très fort c'est
parti je suis très heureuse parce que je
suis mandaté par tirer à luna rossa pas
longtemps je vais rencontrer et le star
qui va faire une énorme surprise
un jeune couple qui se marie je suis
contente de douar installe toi je te
coûte ce soir tu vas être un homme
extrêmement attendu tu vois ce très joli
couple 20 minutes david schoonaert qui
se marie ce soir félicitations voilà et
alors elle est complètement dingue de
toi mais froid y est évident si gênante
était d'avis que nous a missionné et
vous qui viennent chanter comme temps
jusqu'à quand alors il ya scénario de
dingue tu vas être complètement
transformer complètement gris mais tu es
prêt voilà bien j'ai presque fini
salut les amis bat valentin j'espère que
tu seras fier allez c'est parti
[Musique]
franchement regarde moi est
méconnaissable
je t'assure
une version très moche de moi peut-être
coeurs cuda
gerbe raison que c'est moi qui vais me
marrer ça y est on est arrivé
premier
[Musique]
ça y est c'est le moment tu es prêt je
force
[Musique]
harel faire
alors alors regarder dans les yeux ton
coeur il battait à 1000 non mais tu es
parti trop vite j'ai même pas utilisé
dans de nombreux noms mais je vous
laisse penser je voulais deuxième
passage je tremble j'ai le coeur qui bat
francs
[Musique]
la chaussure qu'elle m'a vue elle a rien
grillé elle a regardé le vert l'indienne
et je bois pas
elle a dit je bois pas tout ce que j'ai
pu entendre merci hein quand vous êtes à
côté de moi je suis réconforté chez le
coeur à trois milles à l'heure
[Musique]
chez public pour toi quelqu'un du tas
les âges je te laisse regarder ces
cadeaux mon amour je vais intégrer que
d'habitude et shona ce mardi j'ai la
soirée de l'année
salut shauna ma belle c'est david ton
mari qui m'a contacté pour que je te
reste une petite surprise
alors malheureusement je ne peux pas
être présent ce soir mais je suis de
tout coeur avec vous et j'espère que
vous kiffez et j'espère que vous vous
amusez parce que c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on se marie je vous souhaite
tout le meilleur du monde une vie
amoureuse parfaite et plein de beaux
enfants vous embrasse très très fort
félicitations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une deuxième surprise pour toi mon amour
c'est pour toi tellement d'amour je
t'aime je sais
[Musique]
je cherchais
m
or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
c'est la peur qui domine
sauna
oh
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout d'abord il m'a dit des choses
à je sais que ça va être un bandeau
grâce à valérie bénaïm et grâce à new
york et warm il a un moment qui sera
gravée dans vos têtes
avi asie franchement franchement c'était
le meilleur cadeau de mariage qu'on
aurait pu me faire vraiment merci
beaucoup et merci à valérie oui merci
beaucoup d'allégations pour ce que tu as
trouvé vraiment incroyable incroyable et
ça peut être pas que le tas mottaki
photo doc mec j'ai vu sur le coup
j'étais un peu gêné mais je me dis ça à
venir c'est pas moi ma meuf actifs rené
la taupe j'ai pas mieux au mariage
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup et on vous souhaite
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de bonheur
vous êtes formidables merci les chiens
merci d'avis